[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo
en sixty Moms es una aplicación móvil
que está ayudando a las madres del mundo
árabe acceder a información rápida útil
y confiable sobre la salud física y
mental de sus hijos esta herramienta les
permite conectar con cientos de expertos
en diversos temas y la iniciativa nació
ante el desafío que supone la ausencia
de recursos creíbles en internet y el
tradicional voz a voz a través del cual
se propagan prácticas inexactas Aquí les
contamos la historia empezamos
Dina Abdul Magic es una madre jordana de
dos hijos que ante la frustración de no
poder acceder a información confiable
sobre la salud física y mental de sus
niños además de métodos de crianzas
contemporáneos decidió lanzar en 2017 un
sitio web que tres años más tarde se
convertiría en una exitosa aplicación
móvil Thunder and sixty Moms
Esto fue debido a la ausencia en línea
de recursos creíbles para la salud de
los niños y algo en común que sucede con
las madres en el mundo árabe Y es que se
preguntan entre sí directamente sin
consultar a médicos y especialistas
la mayor parte de esa información es
inexacta eso afecta al futuro de la
familia y su salud
permite a las familias conectar
directamente con profesionales son más
de 300 expertos y médicos a los que los
padres y madres pueden hacer preguntas
específicas el pediatra feras rabia
habló sobre la importancia de que
existan este tipo de aplicaciones
si preguntas en cualquier aplicación
donde cualquiera pueda responderte Es
peligroso porque la familia confiara en
la información que proviene de una
fuente poco confiable y por lo tanto los
niños pueden verse afectados mientras
que si la información proviene de una
fuente confiable y la persona que
responde está bien informada
una sensación de alivio de que la
familia esté recibiendo información
científica que beneficia a los niños
se estima que alrededor de 500.000
usuarios visitan el sitio web
mensualmente y 60.000 personas se han
suscrito a la aplicación desde su
lanzamiento la página web está
disponible en dos idiomas árabe e inglés
y aunque algunos servicios son de pago
hay una gran cantidad de material al que
se puede acceder de forma gratuita por
ejemplo hay artículos y videos en
distintas categorías sobre el embarazo
la lactancia la salud de la madre y el
bebé así como la alimentación consejos
de estilo de vida y hasta testimonios y
en la sección de pregunte a los expertos
los interesados pueden Añadir sus
propias preguntas y hasta encontrar
dudas que ya han sido resueltas
previamente entre sus usuarios regulares
se encuentra van a batanieje madre de
dos hijos quien dice que recibe muchos
consejos útiles de 3 anders six
360 mams realmente me ayudó Porque al
principio había muchos problemas que
desconocía Especialmente cuando se trata
de niños pequeños regularmente uso la
aplicación y Leo las preguntas de las
personas para aprender de sus
experiencias a veces no sabía cómo
formular una pregunta específica o no
pensaba en hacer una por lo que recibía
nuevos consejos que me ayudaban a tratar
con mis hijos
la aplicación me ayudó a ahorrar tiempo
y esfuerzo porque no hay necesidad de ir
a un médico y esperar mucho cada vez que
tengo una pregunta específica puede
abrir la aplicación fácilmente y enviar
mis dudas o buscarlas para ver si fueron
respondidas con antelación realmente me
ahorra tiempo
cambiamos de tema y hablamos ahora de
Netflix si usted le está prestando la
contraseña de su cuenta a otra persona
esto le interesa la plataforma de
streaming ya empezó a cobrar una cuota
extra por ello en España Canadá Nueva
Zelanda y Portugal tal como empezó a
implementarlo en varios países de
América y funciona así de ahora en
adelante los suscriptores de Netflix
deben configurar la ubicación principal
de todos los usuarios que viven en la
misma casa eso no les impide acceder a
sus cuentas desde otras ubicaciones u
otros dispositivos cuando por ejemplo se
encuentran de viaje Si desea darle
acceso a alguien más que no vive en el
mismo techo eso tendrá un costo extra
que varía dependiendo del país pero qué
pasa si un individuo que no reside en la
misma ubicación principal sigue
utilizando la cuenta del titular de
manera gratuita según reportó la revista
Netflix podrá detectar si un dispositivo
que se encuentra fuera de la residencia
principal sigue accediendo a la cuenta
después de cierta cantidad de días Si es
así procederá a bloquearlo la empresa
estima que 100 millones de hogares
comparten actualmente sus cuentas con
otros lo que afecta su capacidad para
invertir en Nueva programación
valoramos a nuestros suscriptores y
entendemos que tienen a su disposición
muchas opciones de entretenimientos cada
cuenta de Netflix está diseñada para un
solo hogar y los suscriptores pueden
elegir entre varios planes con distintas
características
después de la nueva normativa los
usuarios que se han visto afectados
impulsaron en internet el numeral Adiós
Netflix a través del cual han expresado
su inconformismo y también compartieron
fotos que dan constancia de que
cancelaron su suscripciones e instalaron
a otros usuarios a hacer lo mismo y a
trasladarse a otras plataformas otros
internautas aprovecharon la oportunidad
para citar un tuit de Netflix que
publicó en 2017 y en el que decía amar
Es compartir la contraseña de una cuenta
Aunque hoy en día no piense lo mismo
de esta manera despedimos este episodio
de revista digital recuerde que si
quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer A través
de nuestra página web www.trans24.com
[Música]